Film Courage: From the moment that you told
your wife you wanted to be a filmmaker, what
immediate changes did you make in your life in?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer: In terms
of craft or trying to understand, it was
reading and studying everything I could about
about writing, about how how it's structured or
how people format and just the basics of things.I
kind of took it as my own way of going making my
own school of like I want to learn this this is
this is interesting I just can't write on a napkin
or or legal pad I just wanted to see that I guess
I could but I didn't so the changes I made was was
really making a commitment to trying to get better
at it wasn't a thing like I said this is going
to be a career it was a thing that was likeI just
wanted to do it so I didn't know if it was even
going to be something feasible that that didn't
even cross my mind it just it gave me something
that I could wake up and do and challenge myself
and I just never reached a point where I was
frustrated enough to quit I think that was
that was what the screen rang because obviously
once you have a script then you needed to
produce the thing so you have to
shoot the thing and then I think
I just got I just tried to do it all because
it seemed fun call call my friends up or
my family and go hey could you just come could
we just spend this weekend and then we and and do
this and and then that's how it all began just
to see if I could do it from start to finish
so and then whenIdid a short film it was
fun it was I liked the whole process the
storyboarding the getting people together mapping
things out and seeing the words come alive
from from actors or or family members I
don't know I would call them actors but but
they were gracious enough to help me out so you
said previously you went to a bookstore that was
in Texas sorry was it in Dallas or where yeah
Dallas it was half it's called half price books
which people would sell back their books and
had you could get all these books for really
cheap and things like that soI
I would buy a whole bunch of
books on directors books on I think I
got that Robert Rodriguez book there the
rebel book [Rebel Without A Crew] and then I
got a couple other tons of other things and then
I would search for script online to read thank
goodness for the internet I mean it's like you
could just get anything you want and that's what
I helped me. Just trying to learn and get better.
Were there other writers in the Dallas area
or was that something that was not part of
the culture at that time? There's I’ve always
wish I was able to be more gregarious or open
get involved more in the community or specifically
the film community or theater. I just wasn't able
to do that at that point because I think I
didn't know where Iwas headed myself soIjust
started just to writeIthink it was such
an isolating and freeing thing butIi
really didn't meet too many other filmmakers at
the time because I didn't think I was one I was
just trying to write and figure it all out I sort
of did the same thing with my photography career
and there's many ways where you you could go you
could become an assistant you can do this I just
called myself wrote a business plan and called
myself a photographer and shot as many things
as I can weddings and and things I could and
figure out lighting and all that kind of stuff
and then I think I work better that way it might
not be the right way but it at least I could kind
of like know understand what i'm doing wrong but I
oftentimes I wish I did have a mentor group and go
hey what's my second act tanks why am I why am
I always drowning in this and they could say you
don't have this there's not a defined goal there's
this blah blah blah blah but I was really honest
because if you read a script like ordinary people
if you read a script like Leaving Las Vegas
and then you read your script you got to be sort
of honest and go that's not close yet you got to
work on that why how come I can't why am I turning
each page like these other scripts that I love and
that was the same thing when I was a photographer
when I looked at photos in the magazines
I had to go I to be a photographer or working
photographer the hard truth is my photos
have to look as good or better than this so until
I was able to do that and gain the confidence
I was just hard on myself in that way so I just
got to get better whether it took two days or two
years or 15 or 10 I was ready to put in put in
that because I don't know why you just kind of
like keep going because you wanted to get better I
think so I took the same approach with filmmaking
and screenwriting I wanted to write scenes that
made me turn the page myself yeah do you think
it's okay to just not be part of a group there's
a lot of pressure especially in western culture
to be part of a group and join something and do
all that and that's great some people really rise
to the occasion I think some people are better
just by themselves internally yeah that's a great
I think it's up to your personality and I
think you need to find that balance it's
like sort of like dieting I guess it's like you
can't do one extreme especially with filmmaking
writing itself is so alone but the filmmaking
process is so collaborative so you need to
work with other for others and be be able to do
that so so that's what I wanted to do I wasn't
wanted to strictly be a writer I wanted to
work with other people but I love the isolation
of the writing process but now I’ve
learned the the beauty of rewriting and
the input of other people and and and and
getting notes and and getting hey this is
you gotta get into the to it faster
you gotta do this oh this is maybe not
so right for the for the story so I like taking
notes because it gets me to think of other things
because when you're writing for a script it could
take you three six months four months whatever
you're so alone and that maybe that's why
other people have writing partners so you
could bounce ideas but to get notes it gives
me an idea oh I never thought about that let me
plug that in and maybe I come up with something
else it's pretty freeing for me to to do that and
not take it personal and maybe I’m just more
optimistic that go like people are telling you
this not because they don't want you to make a
crappy story it's because they think it could
help and it's your job to synthesize all that
information and see if does I think that's what
happens that's even being a director because
you get like so much information and so many
decisions you have to make and you have
to make it within split seconds sometimes
hey is this makeup too heavy hey what's the
color that closed or is this location work on
are we going to do another take does this the
actor feel safe things it just happens so much
so you really have to be on your toes
and and be adaptable I think that that's
a vital skill even for screenwriters is
to be adaptable and to take notes well
and feedback criticism and go just get back to
work and and take it and what you could do it
you make a version of the notes you
could do it and if you don't like it
you go back to the previous version and continue
that way but at least you shouldn't have a
if you follow that process for at least for me
I wouldn't have a writer's block because someone
gave you a door go to this door it might might not
be the right door but you get to go through it so
you could write that out it doesn't fit I didn't
feel right or maybe I’m missing that scene we need
to add that scene in again so it's interesting
process it's definitely sculpting it's you could
continuously keep writing it's it's weird
something maybe it's it's funny just to drop
the pin and stop writing it because I can I could
I’ll re-read this re-read the script constantly or
the first page the first line and go I gotta stop
and I’m a little obsessive now I take a break and
even the rhythms would read it out
loud the feel of the words flow right
so that's that's what I because
I would imagine if I was a reader
if I was reading this and if it's boring or that
exposition's too long or the state or the scene
heading is too long I need to cut that out so
that's that's sort of my process lately is cutting
I think that's being an editor because I edit as
well so you get used to cutting pieces together
looking back on it now do you think you made the
right choice for yourself choosing the filmmaking
path knowing that you wanted to challenge
yourself it sounds like you don't compete with
others you kind of are very much about challenging
yourself maybe I’m wrong if I think about it and
I'm very lucky to be able to make that
choice and feel like it is the right choice
certainly it's not the easiest of paths to take
it's not like if you go to get your bachelor's and
you get your masters or phd and then you do your
residency and you do this you're and you pass a
license that you're going to be a psychologist
there isn't like routes and and there isn't
a structure that even determines that you are so
there's well there was blind faith I think it just
more of like you do something and then you get
obsessed about it and you do everything you can
to make it happen I think that's just what
happened what happened to me and filmmaking
ended up being a mediI was drawn to because I kind
of failed at everything else I was I wanted to be
a musician and that didn't work out I want to be
a writer that I didn't that didn't work out and
I was got into photography and I got this and I
was like wow you could combine that on that's what
filmmaking was called I never even knew that was
possible so once knew that the possibilities of it
it maybe I felt like a kid again I was
like so I think that's what drove me in
in in telling a story visually with music with
sound that was I was hooked line and sinker and
coming up coming up with stories each time
and developing that and then now working with
actors working with art department working with
the crew you're like whoa this is awesome you you
you asked me before about being isolated but now
you get to get out of your hibernation and then
play with everyone I think that's the fun part
about filmmaking and I think you said just off
camera you knew what you didn't want and so yeah
that's a yeah exactly exactly I was very good at
good at that I was i'd maybe not didn't know what
I want but I knew what I didn't want and that's
the same thing with like if I compose something
in a frameI know I didn't want that in the frame
I don't want that in a frame so what is it that
you that's left in the frame so I took this
similar approach I didn't want this to happen
I didn't want to have regrets I didn't want to
because I did I had those before I wasted time
I wasted this I didn't have confidence I didn't
have these things and and so when I started
like you asked I just started one day at a time
to see if I enjoyed it and then if I didn't
I probably would have been obsessed with
making ramen noodles that'll be the next thing
how do you make those news how did I get it
right texture oh is this broth right okay then
you want to sell it then you want to do it so I
probably would have been obsessed with something
else if I didn't fall in love with filmmaking.
Question For The Viewers: What did
you like about this video?